in Milwaukee and Minneapolis getting
things was a lot easier for me because I
was a big fish in a small pond as far as
like my type there weren't a lot of like
african-american male actors in that
area so it was easier almost for me to
you know get roles I walk in to audition
like walk away feeling I got that easily
like here I look in like audition call
for like a 20 to 30 male
african-american actors and I walk in
and like 12 you know like then give all
my competition right now I'm illegal 18
so I think that it's really important to
embrace that and compete with the 15
year olds for those 15 year old roles so
definitely the teenage girls and Disney
Channel Nickelodeon type of things I
love it and I embrace it well I think so
often as an incredible just multifaceted
selfish or black woman a lot of the
roles that I see on breakdown services
because now i don't have my agent here
so i'm looking at they tend to not
always be as Laird as I like be as fresh
the language is not always they're not
always as interesting and I think that's
one of the greatest things about being
an artist and being an actress is that
we can tell these really wonderful
stories and I'm attracted to great
writing because I'm a writer as well but
so often um when I'm looking at these
casting notices sometimes it can be very
stereotypical um they want us to put us
in just like the ghetto box and I don't
think because if you know the route in
the history of ghetto you know it did
not begin with african-americans so it's
just it's layered but I think that I
feel very blessed because even though
I'm not a household name
I'm not making millions of dollars yet I
still know how to say no I don't have to
say yes to everything and I don't how
can a person with the last thing like
mine play someone who's British or if I
talk like this like well I'm from East
LA which I was born in Boyle Heights you
know I mean I don't look like that so
again I didn't fit in so that's that was
my dilemma and I really virtually gave
up in the sad part not only giving up
but all these years it's almost the same
I see young people or young roles i just
read the LA Times not too long ago and
they have all these up-and-coming you
know young people roles in there was not
one one Hispanic or Latin you know yeah
up-and-coming young actor or actress you
know it's it's always the majority are
Anglo or calc Asian there's a few
sprinkling of this Indian and and of
course the African Americans are black
so but Hispanics it's been a very tough
road for us and that's why I've been
doing stand-up comedy too because it's
like it's my thing it's me it's I write
my material I perform it it's it's me
and it's Who I am from inside and no one
can tell me no you can't do that so it's
if I don't do it myself then it's I
don't see anyone else casting me unless
it's like a person that's on the same
page and it's like hey you'd be great at
this and let's cast you as it I traveled
back to the Philippines back and forth
just because when I was 14 I was offered
a contract there and the Philippines
just a saying so that is it up for a
while and then I told my dad I miss
acting because acting and the
Philippines is way different from the
acting here in America like um in the
Philippines are more dramatic I think
just because of the culture because of
course everywhere is different but being
the Philippines they wanted more like if
you're going to cry you must cry that's
the thing you must see tears in the eyes
but here it's like if you can cry you
can with
you know what I mean it's really chill
but um I was really fortunate that I got
a contract there but then I told my dad
I miss acting in America I just missed
like playing different roles because
here it's really different i get to play
the main girl the I know someone being
mentally ill like those hard difficult
roles like I miss trying to go into
roles like that and like in the
Philippines they don't have feels like
that whatsoever it's basically like
there's the bad girl the good girl then
like or the bad stepmom and something
like that's basically cliche but I just
miss acting here ago said that I need to
come back they don't we don't have a lot
of like black people or like even mixed
people even or in the industry at all so
when we get people who are of a
different skin color or from a different
cultural background they are put in the
most typical stereotypes that they are
out there so if they're Japanese you
know they're very traditional and they
walk around in the kimono if they're
black you know they're ghetto and
they're very Shady Germany is not very
broad in that aspect I would say but
that's only from what I have seen so far
it could be you know that there are some
like independent movies that try to
break out of there but all of the big
blockbusters in cinema from like Germany
that were produced there or all white
and if they're not they're just very
stereotypical they're not very open as I
would say to if it's in film in theater
they don't really care or at least that
was my experience because I never had a
problem but in movie and film they're
very um yeah they're very boxed and keep
to himself which means like white
everywhere so you think America is
actually more progressive um it's
getting there yes I do think so because
I have the feeling there are more roles
now that can be played or that are open
to be played by mixed races or by you
know anybody really if you're good you
can play the role I do feel that it's
slowly going that way when it's like a
very slow slow so